2023 is the year where a lot of us have
to learn it's not just about how much
money you make but it's how much money
you save defense wins championships and
articles like this are something that a
lot of you may want to consider digging
into over the next two or three weeks as
we head into 2023 so many of us have so
many things we raise money on you know
many people right now if they looked at
their credit card statement are paying
renewing monthly payments for [ __ ] that
they don't even use their fourth
streaming service a gym membership from
two years ago some other random [ __ ]
because they clicked preview one time
and it's been charging them whether it's
really cleaning up where you're getting
charged monthly whether it's being
smarter at the grocery store and food
stores whether it's just being more
thoughtful about the [ __ ] you buy a
great great defense in 2023 I think is
going to really help a lot of people and
so I just made this video with real deep
hopes that it's like oh [ __ ] you know
what he might be onto something let me
let me go check my statements or let me
cut out something I don't need in 23.
yeah I like it